it's August 21st 2017 the day of the
total solar eclipse I am in Madras
Oregon the skies are clear this is my
sky tracker it's meant to move the
camera with the sky so it sir
compensates for the Earth's rotation
that should help me keep the Sun in shot
as the Eclipse is taking place we have
first contact this is c1 you just see
the moon entering on the top right side
[Music]
we are 17 minutes out from totality and
I think the light is starting to change
I think it's getting noticeably dimmer
there's a bit of like a cold wind coming
in from this side can you guys feel it
it's getting kind of cool and it's
getting darker I'm really excited now
[Music]
that the Sun is about 90 percent covered
I'm seeing much sharper shadows normally
shadows they're a little bit fuzzy
because the light from the Sun is coming
from a whole bunch of locations but now
because it's coming from basically one
little sliver of the Sun the shadows are
all getting very very sharp
[Music]
oh my god oh my god this is insane right
now oh this is just unbelievable what is
happening this is absolutely insane
breathe
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
this is totally creepy oh my goodness
this feels
oh my goodness there's like sunset
sunrise every direction people are going
nuts this I did not expect I don't know
what I expected but you can see these
prominences the solar corona coming out
at the top left and right at the bottom
I can see Venus directly above me what I
just don't even know we are inside
totality I just it is just unreal right
it's totally nuts
[Applause]
our excitement the Sun is back the solar
filter back on
[Music]
I just want to say a huge thank you to
my patreon supporters you made it
possible for me to buy a flight here and
for the equipment that kept my camera
tracking with the Sun and the solar
filters on the front and yeah basically
everything I needed to get here and see
this total solar eclipse so thank you so
much for supporting me you make it
possible to keep doing the things I love
doing and making these videos